dans cette cabane on a découvert quelque chose de terrifiant
bienvenue aux petites filles
elle est méchante avec moi fais quelque chose ouais qu'est ce
que c'était que les enfants tu veux
l'adopter ici bonjour désolé mauvaise
fenêtre pour survivre à leur
isolement extrême les filles ont créé une sorte d'
imaginaire  Gardien, ils l'appellent maman,
ils ont l'air de super enfants, doc, nous allons le
ramener à la maison, c'est nous allons vous protéger
et nous assurer que rien de mal ne sache que quelque chose de
surnaturel s'est déchaîné.
d'autres
effets personnels ici, c'est juste pour que je puisse courir
chercher des fantômes et des résidus de démons Hé,
c'est voler des démons, j'ai mon poing homme
salut nous recherchons un livre qui peut
arrêter les mauvais esprits certains livres
ne devraient jamais être lus vaut la peine de te barata
nikto  Je vais tous mourir ce soir, mec,
tout est foiré, certains moments
ne devraient jamais être enregistrés.
rien à avoir peur
non je suis revenu de pire que ça
ouais et certaines portes ne devraient jamais être ouvertes
et n'entrez pas là-dedans
je ne le ferais pas tu n'es
pas mon patron je
filme un dollar  me fait hurler
miel boucher